quanto è passata l'ultima volta che ho
giocato sta roba non solo per fare
chiarezza
4 a madonna al fair mario e supermario
poco cattolico vi farò vedere perché in
realtà e supermario solo che ci sono
delle cose che non vanno bene ad esempio
che questo gioco tipo ti prende ti per
kula un pochettino
ecco in questo modo allora signori ha
poi del fatto che non mi ricordo
assolutamente nulla visto che sono
passati cinque anni miley nt che la
madonna ci sarà un motivo
sarà un motivo se non ciò che ho messo
mano sopra ragazzi niente che era morta
ieri di epatite problema è che io vedo
anche dove muoio non mi ricordo più solo
ma perché sono morto lì al che prima va
gonna cosa devo fare a parte che non
posso andare più avanti a meno che non
salti rientrante aiuto solo passa questi
blocchi di sotto tua sorella li passati
sotto ci aveva ragione però solo dalla
seconda parte porca vacca allora un
attimo che devo arrivare alla fine devo
far vedere a tutti i miei followers che
so fare le cose
dio esiste ma non mi sta aiutando
all'area mag n no no l'onore sono molto
prima li ci sono molto prima li se ci
sono molto prima perché devo morire
ciacco adesso ne dietro schifo perché
perché port colme di bizet
dai che sono passati 5 schifosissimi
anni madonna
[Musica]
ok i checkpoint sono effettivamente
check point non è una trappola
by fantastico ringraziando iddio almeno
questo gioco c'è il check point ma
perché giochi come tipo ragazzi poveri
non ce l'hanno
porca merda niente da fare
devo riuscire a fare a livello uno in
codice sono dieci
chissà che non mi incazzai allora se non
riesco a fare sta parte giuro mi faccio
prete vado con matteo in bici a ci sono
i commenti tirando il pugno a tastiera
l'ho scoperto fucking games.it game
diego de mierda è come darvi torto
allora facciamo così vedo sempre allora
il primo non funziona abbiamo detto no
il primo funziona ok ok no però sono
ancora vivo attenzione come avevo fatto
a finirla avevo finito il ragga pensate
che vita sociale deve un tempo veniva
che sia cambiato tanto è porco il
maledetto surreal power non riuscirò mai
finire questo gioco perché ho deciso di
rifarlo so solo io attenzione
voglio bancali di [ __ ] fuori dalla mia
casa adesso devo riuscire ad arrivare
almeno a livello ci sono dieci livelli
almeno a 5 modo tale che non divide in
due parti almeno cinque ma forse no poi
c'è scritto watch out ed è l'unica parte
che è che è sana ma porca eva non
caderci dentro no tranquillo zio io
salterei direttamente sul corso beige o
mancato però meno male ci passò sotto
[Musica]
non facciamo commenti retate e brett
altro la cosa bellissima e che sotto ti
consiglia di giocare a kate mario sembra
per il culo allora passiamo cd sotto
anche di questo ok allora cosa devo fare
beh come come arrivo di là forse forse o
che forse questa parte aiuto aiuto
perché mai per cava che avevo fatto le
cose belle dai cavolo family friends di
tensione
no ma ragazza come faccia arrivare a
livello 5 come ho fatto una volta era
impossibile madonna che ansia di vivere
calmi ma per tra tutti i punti dove
potevo cadere il suo a scapoli e poi
sapere le cose
le puoi sapere madonna che c'è poi per
un attimo avevo pensato di non prenderlo
pensate va bene chi se ne frega
[Musica]
c'è un punto sano da dove visto buttando
ok ok aiuta ma dai cosa stava succedendo
nel mondo della pizza stavo riuscendo a
fare le cose bellissime non sapere
anch'io come come ho fatto a fare sta
roba è segno è firmata cosa parlo a fare
riproviamoci devo andare su quello che
c'è scritto di swann madonna il buco il
buco il buco ho beccato il buco l'unico
punto che c'è ma dai
ok ok ok maledizione e poi domandare a
quello dopo per forza madonna che ansia
perché psicologia inversa siccome this
one prima era giusto adesso dovrebbe
essere sbagliato però l'autore del gioco
pensa che sia sbagliato e quindi io vado
su quello giusto
[Musica]
io devo andare direttamente al traguardo
e siamo a due
me ne mancano mille pensa che questo era
uno dei primi video che ho portato sul
canale perché era ancora al 2013 quindi
tra i primissimi video proprio no è
apparsa la scritta non tutto è come
sembra però va beh non posso andare
avanti allora se il deficiente devo
saltare direttamente dopo e non posso
non posso farne uno nell'altro ma
spiegami posso però non ci vado avanti
non ci posso andare a due vado scusa no
ragazzi possiede a sinistra pure pure
[Musica]
rago bisogno di una pausa vi giuro mista
non impatta il cervello ok dai porca
vacca
ma perché madonna che vivono fare così
brutti si giochi la guarda guarda guarda
no no no no non devo toccarlo quello mai
nella vita nel mondo era un altro
nascosto basta vi prego di andare a
mangiare o fame tardi perché dai stern
inchiodato al muro che regga vi giuro la
musichetta mi sta entrando nel cervello
mi sto diventando scemo più scemo
deprima vado sotto neanche sotto perché
tua madre sotto non ci sta cosa devo
fare qua ma coda dal nulla
ok sottosopra sotto pietro monco l'ho
già detto un importo preso c'è poi me ne
sbatto al mio dio goomba for your
entertainment lo sapevo
ci ho provato solo per il check point
vicino guarda niente neanche così porca
eva
ma perché perché perché devo continuare
a fare ste cagate perché perché quanto
ciò che ho fatto a far cinque livelli in
un video solo come che sono andato via
perché sono andato lì ma che problemi
olio nell'andare nel punto sbagliato
ogni volta macao
mi si è chiuso internet allora allora va
bene
meno male che non abbiamo evitato una
guerra nucleare ragazza che poi tanto
non è che l'abbiamo evitata perché
dovrei farmi tutto il primo punto quindi
in teoria potrai cristo nare uguale ho
tirato un pugno alla tastiera è il
rigore iniziare livello mette bizet
morti
[Musica]
che fastidio sto gioco madonna guarda
madonna dipendesse da me ma io mi farei
estirpare dalla faccia della terra
se dipendesse da me non lo tiro perché
sono demonizzata cup che poi non si sa
con chi ragionamento se io ti rompo la
tastiera mi misi riavvia livello cosa
clicco doveva domo
[Musica]
guarda guarda lascia perdere fa mettere
fammi finire sto schifo per cortesia
space next level ai will kill you barra
ci credo frate problema è che ci sono
degli ostacoli davanti a me non sei tu
che mi ammazzi sugli altri ci vedevo why
are young
io devo printer scappare la sto tizio
nel mentre ci sono pure a meno che non
si debba saltare sopra se io clicchiamo
su next level mi mandava al livello
successivo subito fantastico meno male
che me ne sono accorto quasi subito
grazie a dio per stavolta direi ogni
tanto mi diverte a registrare ogni tanto
no signori direi che possiamo concludere
qui per questo episodio che sono
estremamente soddisfatto di me stesso ho
dato prova di coraggio supremazia e
autocontrollo
quello che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
continueremo le prossime pisodio di
affermare io per adesso no per adesso
grazie agli uomini piace chiarito che mi
dà notizia sostiene sicilia
[Musica]